direct-to-consumer genetic testing is an
opportunity for people to get access to
the same kinds of tests we use to study
the genetic basis of diseases
to understand how their own genomes can
tell them something about their ancestry
or their own health information i
haven't yet decided either way whether
i would actually do the test myself i
think i probably will
i got the test as a present i was mostly
interested
in my health risks but at the same time
i was worried about the psychological
impact that the results would have on me
if i found out that i'm a carrier of
some
nasty disease genes so i'm a bit of a
hypochondriac
i'm the sort of person who if i feel a
little bit sick i'll
search for those search those symptoms
on the internet and then immediately
diagnose myself with some fatal disease
and i suspect i would do the same thing
if i had the genetic information
i didn't have any particular concerns
before i taken the test
mainly because i'm quite lucky in my
family have
a quite healthy health history so it
wasn't any particular
disease that's running down the family
tree i've been to spend a lot of time in
my life
working on my my sort of family history
my genealogy and
at some point you've researched sort of
a dead end path and there'd be a lot
more
research to do in archives all over the
world and i think direct to consumer
testing is a really interesting way to
be able to sort of
um quickly get an answer and potentially
get connected with other people who are
doing the same kind of research
so when you sign up for one of these
direct consumer tests
you give some information to the company
and they post you a box with a little
tube inside
and they ask you to send back a saliva
sample
i did it together with some friends and
we all got together to
dribble into these tubes and try to fill
them to that line
and it doesn't seem like much but it's
actually when you're trying to produce
that amount of saliva on demand it's
kind of a disgusting thing to do
so after you send back your speed sample
you have to register the sample online
you have the option of answering some of
the questions regarding your health
history and lifestyle which will be
further used for research purposes
a few weeks later you get an email that
they tell you that they've received your
sample
they've run the genetic tests that they
do and you can log into the website to
get access to your information for the
first time
the information was presented in two
forms one is my raw dna data
and the other one is the service trying
to help me to
interpret those data so it has the
ancestry component
and also a long list of different type
of diseases and
whether i'm more likely to get the
disease or less likely compared to the
average population
so i was surprised actually that i'm
that healthy i was expecting the worst
from
from my genetic tests i was reading
about all these nasty diseases and how
you can be a carrier of them
but in the end it turns out i was pretty
healthy
prior to taking the tests i was excited
about the possibility of getting this
genealogical information
and i was interested in the potential to
have the health reports but i didn't
really think there was anything that
could harm me in the information i think
you know
having more information about yourself
can only be a good thing after i
received my results
i was going through the health reports
and
um looking at you know by various
different slightly changed
risks of various diseases and traits and
one of them in particular
um really had an effect on me i was i
wasn't expecting this at all
but um the particular trait was
something that in my childhood i had a
friend who died from it
and so i was like really concerned about
it i just saw that and it was just like
whoa that's data about me and i have a
yellow at risk of this and you know i
just all kind of memories and things
got back and i got basically it
triggered something in me that i wasn't
expecting at all
i think people don't realize how
powerful some of these results can be
and often it's not in the areas you
think it's not necessarily in the
medical areas
but there are many stories in the press
where
people discover stuff about their
ancestry i.e
their paternity or even shared siblings
that they didn't know or half siblings
that they didn't know they have
and these are the sorts of consequences
that can have serious
impacts there were some things that were
totally unsurprising all of my family is
from ireland and my
genome says that i'm essentially 100
irish which is a relief in one sense i
guess
um in terms of the health information
there's some things it
told me that weren't a surprise so it
predicted i have a high risk of
the skin disease psoriasis which is true
because i happen to have it in fact it
does run in my family
and also some totally unsurprising
things like i'm at a high risk for male
pattern baldness
it was very easy to interpret your desi
your results
the website helps you a lot gives you a
lot of information about
what the risks mean and
how high the risks are what's the
average
risk health risks on certain diseases
the health
sections i think um they tend to show
things in terms of relative risk
which means they get to show more
interesting graphics i guess like
you know if you're showing how much
you're changing the risk over the
general population you could be you know
showing a graph maybe with like this
genotype
changes it this much this one changes it
this much and this intention is this
much
and that's a more interesting shape you
sort of see this big change it looks
like
but if you look at that in absolute
terms it's actually that you know your
population risk is this much
and with the genotype change it's like
this much
it's basically the same thing and the
other side although slightly elevated
and so that's the last interesting
picture
and so they think that's reasonable that
they choose to show us relative risk
it's just important that that the people
who are looking at these interpretations
understand what that means and that even
though it looks like a big change in the
graph
it could be representing a very small
sort of absolute change in their risk to
this
particular disease i believe that it's
very important that
information that you get from direct to
consumer genetic test should not be
considered in isolation
it has to be considered in conjunction
with other information related to your
age your lifestyle your diet in exactly
the same way that when you go to your gp
and they're trying to diagnose you they
don't just try and measure one thing
they consider that in conjunction with
lots of other information so that they
can make the right choice about the
appropriate treatment regime
and so in exactly the same way you have
to interpret information from direct
consumer genetic testing in conjunction
with all of the other information about
yourself and then that will help you
make
informed decisions about whether this
information really can provide some
useful insights
that might alter your lifestyle i have
shared my
testing results with my friends and
family
and the reason i'm sharing is one
because
my result was quite positive i had quite
healthy genes
i was quite happy to see how healthy i
am genetically
and also encouraging my family and
friends to
do their genetic testing as well so i
can have more information
as a family i've shared it with family
and friends who also have accounts on
the various sites
so that they can just see everything
about my data because i don't see the
big deal in that
and i've also gone so far as to share it
with with basically strangers um
who the site has connected me with
through my genome basically saying that
you know you share some amount of your
genome you might be related
people are interested to look deeper and
see which parts of your genome you share
to maybe help them figure out their
genealogy
and i've basically said yes to all those
requests as well i was quite careful who
i shared my results with i only shared
them with close friends who also did the
test
out of curiosity to see how my results
are compared to theirs
i think the most critical challenge in
how you present genetic risk information
to people
is to reinforce the uncertainty about
genetic risk information
and these companies i think take that
responsibility very seriously to present
some kind of complicated
concepts like the difference between
relative risk and absolute risk
and differentiating between these two
concepts and understanding that your
genome isn't your destiny
is a very important part of how you
present this information to people
i think if somebody was thinking about
doing a genetic test if i had a friend
who was interested in doing it then i
would say go for it you know you'll
probably discover some really
fun stuff about your dna and you'll
understand what information
there is that we know today about your
dna which is not actually
an awful lot often in your family
history tells you far more
and you probably already know that but
do think carefully about it
talk to your nearest and dearest about
it consider what that might
the implications that might have for
your children or future children for
your parents
so go for it but do think a little bit
about it